brasil sigue enfrentándose al oscuro
panorama de una crisis sanitaria sin
precedentes una de cada cuatro muertes
por kobe 19 en el mundo esta semana se
registró en el gigante sudamericano que
ya roza los 350 mil muertos por la
enfermedad y aún no hay luz al final del
túnel
el ministerio no tiene una varita mágica
para resolver todos los problemas y
estamos trabajando todos los días para
llevar alternativas a la gente de brasil
el presidente y jair bolsonaro se dijo
víctima de activismo judicial después de
que un juez de la corte suprema ordenara
la instalación de una comisión en el
senado para investigar su manejo de la
pandemia argentina también registró este
viernes un nuevo récord histórico de
contagios por kobe 19 superando los
24.000 positivos en 24 horas esto cuando
el mismo ya entró en vigor un paquete de
medidas restrictivas que incluyen toques
de queda nocturnos y límites en las
reuniones sociales medidas que regirán
durante tres semanas pero que dadas las
dificultades económicas encuentran
detractores
de corazón de economía
[Música]
cerrado
con esto el año que viene
chile también tuvo récords más de 9000
contagios en 24 horas por primera vez en
toda la pandemia evidentemente que esta
cifra de más de 9.000 casos es
preocupante
pero nosotros estamos haciendo todos los
esfuerzos posibles para evitar que se
siga propagando el virus y además dar la
atención de salud necesaria para
cualquier persona para cualquier
compatriota para cualquier habitante de
chile que lo necesite por ahora ni una
cuarentena más del 83 por ciento de la
población ni una campaña de vacunación
rápida que ya llega a más de 7 millones
de chilenos han logrado frenar el virus